hello everyone and welcome back to day
four of the Magnus Invitational we were
back in the match Fabiana Caruana versus
ding leerin where after two games that
were drawn dink was able to win that
Queen and Quarantine game and now Fabi
is in a must-win situation he has to win
on demand with the white pieces at get
back into the match and force an
Armageddon so let's see what happened
Fabi opened with e4 and here as he needs
only a Grod thing does not go for the
Sicilian in which he employed so far
against e4 in this tournament but rather
for a 5 sorry about that and he will he
will go for a Berlin defense we have
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 Bishop to b5
and Knight to f6 not even trying to not
to create some sort of a Marshall attack
as he is a Marshall player so he wants a
very solid set up for Fabi to have to
force things we have d3 and Bishop to c5
now Bishop captures on c6 d captures and
Knight B to d2
we have castles by both players and rook
to e8 now by ding Fabi in Bobby goes
King to h1 and it is a new move into
position there is there are a few games
where Knight to c4 was played but as of
move 8 we have a completely new game so
Dean continues with a5 grabs more space
on the Queen side we have Knight to c4
now putting more pressure on e5 and
Knights to d7 now preparing to
strengthen the center with f6 with a 4
by Fabi not allowing further expansion
biding on the Queen side and b6 now we
have b3 and f6 now so now the pond has
been strengthened with eath Bishop to e3
and challenging it dings bishop and the
bishop back the b4 and making it hard
for Fabi to to use the rooks we have
nice the h4 going after the f5 Square
and now Knight the f8 keeping control
that f5 Square would the shop but Fabi
goes to it just as well because even if
Bishop captures pawn character CS you've
doubled White's pawns and you could even
go after a pawn but after Queen h5 it's
not easy to to do anything about that
point so it might not be actually be a
problem for white
so instead Knights that e-cigs biding
and
now Queen to g4 just getting the Queen
into the attack if the knight moves
you're gonna have a nice checkmate here
also Black has to be careful not to run
into some sort of tricks after Knight h6
check so g6
are kicking the knight back but now just
Queen to g3 the knight is off-limits but
you just want to get your queen away
from this diagonal so Bishop the c3
putting pressure on the rook but also
may be planning Bishop to d4 to try and
trade off one of Bobby's attackers rook
a to be 1 and now King to a trade now
there is a threat of capturing the night
so Knights the h6 going after that f7
squared - 4 K the king and the Queen
so Quinta East 7 guarding the f7 square
we have Queen to h4 and now rook to f8
getting more defenders TV f6 square if
knife to g4 comes with h3 and now Queen
to g7 so just putting putting pressure
on that night here g5 is an idea which
will kick away the Queen and block of
the bishops defense of the night so
Knight back to g4 and now g5 just as
well we have Queen back to g3 and now
Knight to f4 and now dink has everything
under control he has a beautiful night
on a Ford the bishop is nicely placed on
c3 and he has a clear idea of what he
wants to do he wants to play h5 and bust
open the Kings side and very exciting
play biting even though he only needs a
draw and yeah someone mentioned this in
the comments and it is in fact true it's
somewhere around the pre noon for Fabi I
think was like 10 11 a.m. and it's past
midnight for ding as he's playing from
China so Bishop to b2 offering a trade
of the bishops and now Knight to e2
biding attacking the Queen while
defending the bishop here so Queen has
to move Queen h2 now shifting the bishop
back to d4 we have night night
jitta III and now comes the Bishop to e6
so just getting a more pieces into the
game
rook the t1 challenging the night and
now Knight back to f4 so doing not
worried about anything Queen back to g3
and Queen to g6 now preparing h5 we have
Queen to f3 and now being starts pushing
on the King side h5 and it really does
seem
it's ding the one like dings the one who
is in a must-win situation not Fabi
we have night the f5 getting that night
two to one a wonderful square but before
capturing it the Dean first goes g4 okay
queen g3 and now Bishop captures on f5
we have it captures and Queen captures
the Dean winds upon and he keeps the
attack
so rook to e4 with some ideas maybe
maybe you can capture here and then pick
up the bishop or maybe just not at the
moment because after captures the point
will also be attacking the Queen but it
is good to have options
so here thing just continues with G
captures and h3 and here Fabi goes
Bishop captures on f4 with it captures
and now Queen captures on h3 so Fabi
manages to stop the attack we have Queen
captures on h3g captures and now c5 just
cementing that Bishop on d4 and rook
captures on f4 and we reach the same
game where it's two rooks against two
rooks and the bishop against tonight
with the same number of pawns so not a
nut and easy easy position to push for a
win for Fabi King h7 with King to g2
both players start improving the
position of their Kings rook 88 bringing
the final rock into the game and king of
three now and now it is an active King
but being finds f5 which really limits
the mobility of this rook the rook
doesn't really have anywhere to go so
nicely three going after the f5 point
and now Bishop to g7 thing shows that
it's impossible in fact the capture the
pawn because if you capture with the
rook then just eliminate the defender
with check and then you pick up this
rope for free and then you just straight
down into an endgame which is of course
winning and capturing with the knight
isn't any better because of Bishop e5
forces the rook away from the knight or
not you just give up the exchange so
what would be winning four dings so
Brooke g1 instead and now Bishop to h6
pushing the rogue back look the h4 and
now f4 and now Bobby's rook is really
stuck under h4 and the fabi's pieces
really do get stuck a lot on the h4
square in that previous game we had the
Queen stuck on h4
but okay Knight to d5 and now getting
the Knights into the attack attacking
the c7 point pulling
therefore pawn also if this rope moves
may be nice to have sex check will be an
option so it useful square for the night
we have looked a five now here dink
forces fab it capture on c7 which also
kind of moves the night back away from
the game night captures on c7 and now
rook to f6 so keeping that night away
from the game with c3 and now comes work
to g6 offering to trade one of the rooks
which Fabi declines he needs as many
looks as possible in the game since this
one isn't really doing all that much now
preparing d4 so rook the c6 he goes
after the night we have United the b5
and now King to g6 now Bing is preparing
Bishop to g5 to completely trap the rook
on h4 so Bobby first pushes d4 and now
comes C capture son d4 we have C
captures on d4 and now instead of moving
away with let's say rook d5 to keep keep
an eye on the pawn dingos for rook
captures on b5 and it is in fact the
best move however there is an issue here
Fabi recaptures and here being played
rook the c3 check but there is another
move you can play here so even feel free
to pause the video to try to find this
move while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
remembering that this rook is trapped
here and for those of you who just wanna
enjoy show its work to f6 you add more
protection to the f4 pawn and now the
threat of Bishop to g5 is just happening
whatever wife plays doesn't really
matter
rook c1 or or you put it upon the d5
doesn't really matter Bishop to g5 is
just crushing here you would have to
give up the rook and you don't have
anything good to capture like you could
capture here or error you could maybe
pin would work to g1 but this also
doesn't work because the King simply
moves and now you have to give up either
yeah nothing really works here even
trying to give up the exchange like this
doesn't work because the rook is still
stuck here you can't save the rook so
this was definitely an option for doing
so after rook rook to f6 you would have
to play some like rook to c1 and then
just go after the ship to g5 rook
captures King captures and now let's say
rook to c6 to try and get get a nice
pass pawn here but after something like
that King to g6 were just moving the
rook and black is just clearly clearly
better having a bishop and well why does
not but instead the ding one for rook
the c3 checked he wanted to grab the b3
pawn and probably now when the King to
e4 and now it's a bit different g5 but
now rook to g1 and now it's different as
the f4 pawn is only defended once so
here King to h6 but now Fabi just gives
it back rook captures on f4 the ship
characters and now King captures on f4
rope character son b3 and now d5 and now
it's fabric who's up upon and it's a
past deep on so terrible position for
ding to be in with a for ding also
starts pushing his passport but now rook
to d1 Fabi puts the rook behind the past
pawn now rogue before check we have king
to f5 and now rook captures on b5
grabbing even that point this one is now
pinned King e6 and now it's hard to do
anything about this push of the pawn so
rugby to ding decides that he's gonna
grab as many points as possible
rook e to check we have kinked d5 and
now rook captures an f2 but now just d7
and there is no way to stop this rook to
f8 now comes King to c6 and here we have
King to g5 going after this point but
Bobby just brings a queen enter game
ending is forced to give up the rook so
King to h4 biding but now if Abby just
played rock the d3 and you are not
grabbing this you are never crossing a3
so it was in this position unmoved 64
that Bingley resigned the game and yes
favi was able to win on the man and he
takes this match into Armageddon so
excellent game by Fabi didn't really had
everything under control and then it's
like he forgot that he needed to go
after the trapped rock on h4
really just the crazy stuff but
everything was top-notch that their
sacrifice exchange sacrifice on b5 and
then just not going after that
here after this a character son b5 move
just here and then you just book Bishop
g5 it's it's game over basically but ya
might have something to do with it with
the fact that it's over past me and that
I think was like 1:00 a.m. at the time
the Dean was playing this game so who
knows might have nothing to do with it
might might have been that he's just
tired but yeah that's the game for I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Mark McNair and Iligan Civic for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos er thank
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational
the following video that will be
uploaded is the Armageddon game between
Fabian ding so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day